love time okay so here we go I've
watching this viral video on this girl
who was singing a song but she couldn't
do right so she kept on freaking out I
can show you the hook I can I be sure I
can show you
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh what is going on YouTube hey what is
this now growing up and having a good
amount of friends to listen to all the
relationship problems apparently a lot
of my friends got cheated up that wasn't
supposed to be funny now every time this
happens to a friend I'm pretty sure they
expect you to react how most people
would if it's a dude they always do the
I told you [ __ ] when I tell you about
that huh
didn't I tell you that video for John
Holmes I throw the pencil through a
hallway baby's right here her vagina and
if it's a girl it's always say you're
better than him speech you know what you
are here our unicorn God is that like a
fart sound glitter out your butthole
yeah well for me when my friends always
told me they got done dirty I always
told them the same thing you should have
saw coming my friends there are certain
sides with somebody eaten on you but
it's hard to see when you're the victim
everyone else sees it but you
so let me help you out with this place
oh yeah usually if somebody gets overly
defensive over the phone out of nowhere
oh they cheat don't you know if you're
the type of person that for no reason
you just constantly snooping around this
it does not apply to you because ain't
nobody cheating on you they're just
tired of you being an [ __ ] that's
right love it don't be no thank you
[ __ ] it's dominoes and you said you
wanted pizza so I don't but if somebody
has nothing to hide they shouldn't be
hiding the phone conversations
especially if you're not stupid for
example if you're just casually playing
Angry Birds on his phone and he's like
hell you don't
oh he's cheap when using my Bobo oh you
see what oh oh oh well I think let me
let me tell him in the mirror well most
likely you probably watch a [ __ ] porn
here once you see his browser history so
he was trying to leave the cookies and
[ __ ] look if your father hasn't left you
find out this fight the fact that you
don't give a [ __ ] enough about them to
care about your parents most likely they
step it out
on here nobody this troop is contingent
on the fact that you an [ __ ] and you
just be getting uglier every
but then again a lot of you might say
what about relationship lane it only
works if you get back and she gets back
then you have to Ashley people loving
each other very much perfect you guys
can be butt naked together have a sex
eating Snickers and M&Ms off each
other's backs for the rest of the hall
if you want to stay home be an [ __ ]
and do [ __ ] while the other person goes
down to have fun there finding something
to somebody up that you haven't been
given them in games because in their
mind if you don't give a [ __ ] guess what
you miss it out on a holiday with you
ask them a simple question and they
start stuttering most likely something's
going down for some reason and I think
this is a guy thing well the guy there's
something wrong I don't know why but we
start stuttering like we committed
murder
I'm not to be kidding you I had a friend
that comes with an issue with keeping
his [ __ ] inside his pants every time he
got caught he could not stop [ __ ] was
obvious as but this will get overly
defensive it's not yelling in a for [ __ ]
that don't even make sense
what about my face I'm out of here I
thought why this [ __ ] is cheating on me
when [ __ ] like this happens the first
thing that we want to do is go there and
give our friends advice don't do it let
it calm down a little bit at first and
then after then coming with your two
cents of advice like have you ever said
some [ __ ] about your friend's girlfriend
that you were never supposed to say out
of anger that's right Jimmy that [ __ ]
anyway however she was sucking everybody
mm-hmm we're staying together you know
that right ah congratulations yeah
that's what I meant
listen stop trying to be a hero and just
do what everybody else does just give
two narrative bites and sometimes I just
say random middle and they think it
actually means something
you owe me [ __ ] look Dawg if the Eagle
comes by and he flutters like this with
his feathers all out in the
down the new the scooty one Phoenix
beware of cheaters people because even
if you don't think they might fall into
this category you still might get
cheated up that's life sometimes it
happens everybody gets cheese now at
least one sometimes maybe it's not [ __ ]
is [ __ ] anybody that leaves you or
cheats on you you know what that means
it just means that you just sight
without somebody that wasn't made for
you anyways now on to the next one and
if it were to happen to you in the near
future
guess what I will help you through it
are you ass pop it back at you first I
hope see I left the Guinness you know
saying 400 be 1 item 9
[Music]
and I just wanna say a hello hello again
no tough
[Music]